[Applause]
[Music]
let's be clear fossil fuels are not in
fashion rather they are being condemned
for example many major governments
around the world are launching new rules
regulations and spending plans almost
daily to drive the energy transition
japan's green ambition threatened the
lng market it helped to create japan's
aggressive new plan to champion clean
energy is shaking up the liquefied
natural gas market
biden's
2.25 trillion dollar infrastructure plan
will focus on green energy and
decarbonization and as we have told you
in several of the weekly newsletters
that those of you who join us on patreon
receive each week oil and gas industry
investment is at a 15-year low
report warns global energy crisis
looming without increasing oil and gas
investment shortage could mean higher
fuel prices increased energy poverty and
rise in greenhouse gas levels
it's too late to avoid a major oil
supply crisis david messler an oil field
veteran
[Music]
as it stands we are now less than 30
years away from reaching the deadline
set by many countries including those
belonging to the european union to
achieve complete decarbonization one of
those countries that has set 2050 as the
year in which their heir will be free of
co2 is south korea a country that is
taking the task of designing and
implementing a decarbonization plan that
is really feasible very seriously and
not only technically feasible but also
one that is easy on the wallet and take
note because we are not just talking
about any country
south korea is an industrial powerhouse
and the seventh largest emitter of
greenhouse gases in the world
of the total polluting gases emitted
85.6 come from the energy sector energy
that the korean industrial muscle needs
like the light of day in fact 55 of all
energy consumed in south korea is
consumed by the industrial sector the
highest rate of all member countries
belonging to the international energy
agency
another fact 98 of south korea's energy
sector emissions are produced by burning
fossil fuels and no wonder for example
in the case of electricity production
south korea still produces almost 40
percent of its electricity today by
burning coal and another 27
using natural gas
this explains why overall if we take
into account the energy sector and all
other productive activities such as
transportation south korea's dependence
on fossil fuels is one of the highest in
the world
this is how south korea's economic
muscle works today by burning fossil
fuels and of course given such a
scenario achieving total decarbonisation
of the country by 2050 well i don't know
it seems almost a chimera more a wish
than a feasible option even more so if
we take into account that the current
moon government has also put nuclear
energy in its sites so the question we
could all ask is how on earth does south
korea intend to achieve its targets what
exactly does moon jae-in's government
have in mind well you know what he
recently presented a proposal with three
different possible plans or strategies
have you ever wondered if it is possible
to produce energy with coal or natural
gas without polluting well although it
may seem like science fiction the idea
exists it is real and it is already
being worked on at least that's what
moon jae-in's government claims listen
up
moon jae-in's energy dream
south korea wants to reduce its huge
dependence on dirty energy and at the
same time not or punish its
powerful industrial muscle then the
south koreans are going to have to be
resourceful precisely for this reason
the government in addition to a
multi-million dollar strategy on all
fronts has also concretely presented
three possible plans to adapt the energy
sector to a zero-carbon scenario three
plans that now have to be debated
the first of these plans is for the
country to continue using some of its
coal and natural gas plants practically
indefinitely or at least until they are
fully depreciated to do so they would
employ a novel technique of carbon
capture storage and use known as ccus
yes i know what you're thinking but josh
really where is the novelty if you talk
to me about carbon capture if that is
already known and works elsewhere please
yes you were right but a very important
detail is missing so far these
techniques have not been used to capture
pollutant emissions on a large scale to
be able to achieve this and make it
viable would be in itself something new
and for example according to estimates
by the south korean government the use
of this technique along with the
promotion of hydrogen which we've
already talked about on visualpolitik
electric cars and renewable energy could
allow them to eliminate more than 95
percent of their carbon emissions by
2050 without excessively punishing or
compromising their industrial
competitiveness
the second plan calls for completely
abandoning coal as a generation fuel but
keeping liquefied natural gas as a
flexible energy source to meet peak
demand of course the replacement of coal
would be undertaken with green energies
and finally the third plan would be the
most stringent and costly if it is
adopted country would completely abandon
the use of coal and natural gas by 2050.
these energy sources would be replaced
by renewable energy and green hydrogen
this plan would make it possible to
achieve the so-called zero carbon
scenario but it would of course be the
most expensive to implement
[Music]
the curious thing about these three
proposals is that in all three despite
moon jae-in's mania for it nuclear power
will continue to play a prominent role
so although the government's plans to
gradually reduce its presence in the
south korean electricity mix as there
are several nearly new reactors and even
some currently under construction
nuclear power would not completely be
eliminated until at least 2083
but back to the plans competitive
demands have made the first plan the
favorite in other words even in the zero
carbon scenario part of the electricity
would still be produced with dirty
energy and the question is what
potential does this carbon capture
technology really have how does the
south korean government intend to
convert energy generated by dirty fuels
into clean energy could south korea
become a world leader in clean
non-renewable energy is there really an
alternative well listen up
underground storage
south korea could have a significant
advantage over other countries in
applying carbon capture and storage
technology to power generation a
technique that in 2020 alone prevented
the emission of 40 million tons of co2
into the atmosphere worldwide which may
seem like a huge amount until you
realize that around 35 billion tons of
co2 are emitted worldwide every year now
what are we talking about in the south
korean case well take a look at this
image for a moment at first glance it
just looks like another gas platform but
underneath it hides the latest energy
gamble of the south korean government
the donghae one gas field is located in
the east sea this field will be
decommissioned in 2022 and the idea
would be to use the pipeline that runs
from it to the east coast to transport
polluting gases from coal and natural
gas power plants in this way the south
korean government plans to use the empty
underground space to inject the
polluting gases emanating from
electricity production into the old
natural gas field in addition according
to kwan yi kyun a professor of geo
environmental science at kongju national
university filling in greenhouse gases
in the natural gas well that has already
been extracted would improve the
geological stability of the area
it's by no means the first time
something like this has been proposed
but the south korean project so far
seems to be the most ambitious and
feasible according to estimates by south
korean experts in the field the country
could store some 400 000 tons of
greenhouse gases per year underground in
the donghae one field by 2025 and this
would just be the beginning south korea
claims that by 2023 it will have thanks
to research already underway the
capacity to store annually four million
tonnes of carbon captured on its
continental shelf look at this map
[Music]
the two red dots represent the two
carbon capture facilities that are
currently serving as pilot projects
these are bori yong ko sol and har dong
in addition next to them there are two
other potential locations where co2
storage facilities are expected to be
commissioned in the future but wait a
minute let's not get ahead of ourselves
because what we haven't talked about yet
is the money the hard cash
[Music]
estimates suggest that capturing one ton
of co2 using existing technology would
cost between sixty dollars and seventy
dollars per ton and of course for this
technology to be applicable to power
generation without south koreans having
to pay astronomical electricity bills
the cost per tonne would have to be
reduced to a maximum of 30 and that is
still a long way off
[Music]
will south korea manage to reduce co2
storage costs enough to make this
technique viable well to achieve this
they are investing heavily in rdi but of
course nothing is clear as of today
what's more despite everything with
today's plans and technology we are
still talking about marginal solutions
not a real alternative after all even if
this plan succeeds to meet the zero
carbon strategy would mean that at least
90 percent of energy sources would need
to be clean so having got to this point
i'm sure many of you are asking
yourselves well josh what about nuclear
power why are there so many plans that
are little more than patches that is a
good question nuclear energy is an
energy that does not emit co2 that is
cheap and that more importantly south
koreans understand perfectly well in
fact south korea is one of the world's
major nuclear powers and it also has
advanced local technology capable of
developing manufacturing and even
exporting third generation nuclear
reactors so why turn their backs on the
energy of atoms well this is where the
politics comes in again listen up
[Music]
marginalized energy
have you heard of nuclear power
moratoriums those of you who are
watching us from some european countries
will surely be familiar with the concept
in spain for example it has been applied
since 1994. a nuclear power moratorium
literally means banning the construction
of new nuclear power plants and reactors
well in the case of south korea there is
no moratorium but moon jae-in's
government has been making plans to put
an end to future nuclear power almost
since it came to power
2017 south korea's president moon says
plans to exit nuclear power it's
something that has unleashed a huge wave
of controversy why well because despite
being located on a peninsula south korea
is in practice an energy island bordered
to the north by north korea and with the
rest of the cardinal points facing the
sea south koreans cannot import
electricity from third countries so they
have to make sure they are completely
self-sufficient and not only that they
have to be self-sufficient and
competitive
[Music]
for precisely this reason south korean's
commitment to nuclear energy has
historically been very important to the
point of it becoming the fifth country
in the world after the united states
france china and russia in terms of the
number of nuclear reactors in service 24
in total between them they are capable
of generating more than 23 gigawatts of
electricity accounting for around 26
of the national and electricity mix in
addition south korea has the highest
density of nuclear reactors in the world
that is the highest number of reactors
concentrated in the smallest space we
are talking about no less than 24
reactors spread over only four power
plants
nuclear power requires a large initial
investment but in return it generates
clean cheap and stable energy which is a
major advantage for countries like south
korea that depend on imports and
fluctuating world energy market prices
in fact price competitiveness and
security of supply and stable conditions
for companies have been two factors that
have promoted the industrial and
economic takeoff of south korea for
years
[Music]
despite this the fear that the fukushima
disaster could be repeated in south
korea led munjai in to promise in his
election campaign in 2017 when he was
elected president he would work towards
ending nuclear power and of course to
many political and economic figures in
the country this seems like a whole lot
of nonsense
in fact the presidential election is
coming up in 2022 and the conservatives
have a good chance of winning back the
blue house the south korean equivalent
of the white house and you know what
their position on nuclear power is very
very different
nuclear phase out plan emerging as key
issue in upcoming presidential election
mounting opposition to the government's
nuclear out policy has prompted
presidential contenders from the
opposition bloc to promise to restore
the use of nuclear energy highlighting
the fact that it is the cheapest and
cleanest alternative to fossil fuels in
korea which relies entirely on imports
to meet its petroleum needs in other
words despite all the plans it is not
unreasonable to think that in the end
south korean's answer to zero carbon
will be more nuclear energy as you can
see the rest of the options seem either
very costly and uncertain or directly
unfeasible no matter how much moon
jae-in insists on the contrary the
question is should governments once
again embrace nuclear power as a
realistic option for generating huge
amounts of clean energy you can leave us
your answers in the comments but before
you do take a look at this new story
china is to start up the world's first
uranium free nuclear reactor the asian
country will start testing its thorium
and molten salt nuclear plant in
september this type of reactor is
theoretically much safer than those
currently in operation yes the chinese
are becoming the new leaders in nuclear
technology now if you found this video
interesting don't forget to like and
subscribe to our channel so you don't
miss any of our upcoming videos all the
best see you next time
[Music]